esta semana Canadá tomó una decisión
dificultar el acceso ilegal al país a
para los migrantes a través de un nuevo
acuerdo fronterizo con Estados Unidos
pero es la migración un problema en el
país norteamericano históricamente
Canadá ha acogido ampliamente a
refugiados de Siria Afganistán y otras
naciones como uno de los países más
abiertos del mundo al respecto pero los
cerca de 40.000 migrantes que cruzaron
la frontera en el 2022 han situado el
tema en el centro del debate con la
oposición pidiendo un nuevo pacto con
Estados Unidos todo porque el acuerdo
migratorio de 2004 tiene un vacío legal
según este Canadá solo puede devolver a
los migrantes que pasen por un paso
fronterizo legal pero si cruzan por
pasos no oficiales como el de rothham
Road entre el estado de Nueva York y
Quebec no pueden devolverlos hasta
resolver su solicitudes de asilo hasta
ahora recordemos que dos de cada tres
solicitudes de Refugio que tuvo ya en
los últimos años fueron precisamente a
esta provincia de Quebec y es por ello
que ya la presión política hacia Justin
crudó estaba muy marcada con el recién
firmado acuerdo del Tercer país entre
Washington y Ottawa ambos países podrán
devolver entre sí a los solicitantes de
asilo en un plazo de 14 días un pacto
que según las rutas migratorias desde
América Latina permitirá que Canadá
devuelva muchos migrantes a Estados
Unidos y a cambio el país norteamericano
aceptará 15.000 solicitudes de asilo en
este 2023 una pequeña fracción teniendo
en cuenta que solo en los dos primeros
meses del año ya ha recibido Diez mil
solicitudes
siempre lo viste canada por televisión y
son países mucho bonita y me gustaría
conocerle de sus países para Mora Porque
en mi país hay mucho sufrido una
decisión que endurece la política
migratoria de Canadá y que ya ha sido
criticada por muchas organizaciones de
defensa de los derechos de los migrantes
y refugiados